previously on TV sings
here's Johnny
[Music]
I've watched every single episode of
this show most more than once and I'm on
my eleventh episode of sending these two
full minutes of opening credits and I'm
just now noticing that each actor's name
has the symbol of their character house
next to it my ignorance must be the
show's fault in one way or another isn't
that how this works how about that one
it's available you know once I got
castle shadowing some of the iron bank
will be disappointed they've grown
rather fond of your interest payments
unless I'm missing some sort of
extremely subtle sexual metaphor here we
are now talking about bank interest look
I get that this is the stuff that causes
some fans to want to touch the throne
bone but if we're going to dock star
wars for getting caught up in the Senate
we have to offer a game of Thrones the
same disk courtesy do you know who this
belongs to
no a very question was what started the
war of the five kings
I hope Littlefinger knows what questions
start at the Battle of the five armies
because I sure want to make sure that
never happens again
I'm not saying Isaac Hempstead right is
a terrible actor but I am saying that he
was given the worst storylines and
dialogue on this show maester wolkan
built it for me so I can move around
more easily well tell the maester we are
all impressed with his ability to
combine two such complex ideas as wheels
and a chair I remember what it felt like
to be Brendan stuff and we remember what
it felt like when you were two it felt
much more what story again oh yeah I'm
not wanting to scratch my eyes out every
time I hear that monotone voice of a New
York sadly this might actually make
liver taste better no because if you
don't I don't know if you right in the
face as hard as I can these two have
been fighting for the last minute about
who's going to tell Sansa that Aria is
here and the Monty Python town is so
different than the rest of the show that
I'm just waiting for someone to peek
around a corner and say and now for
something completely different you were
standing right next to her and when we
turned around she'd gone milady
these two don't strike me as the type to
go straight to Sansa and admit their
mistake they seem much more likely to
look the other way pretend it didn't
happen or hide away and sneak some of
that sweet Winterfell cush also it
wasn't the whole point of their comedy
bit fight that all of them had to stay
behind and continue to guard the
entrance what changed
or did they argue for another five
minutes and then decide both to come
anyway
from the gods I didn't run any better
guards and the show needs better writing
for long-awaited scenes such as this it
doesn't look like him should have been
caught by someone who knew his face man
seems like a weird moment for Arie to
brag about her new face changing skills
everyone his face is dead fake news
aside from you two there's John brand
Tyrion Jaime Cersei Theon the Hound
should I go on your list of people I'm
going to kill seems like this make me
realize that characters smile or laugh
so little on the show that when they do
though somehow become the most
uncomfortable moments I'm pretty sure
dragons chargrilling the Sisters Grimm
here would be more joyful than this
exchange how did she get back to
Winterfell long story I imagine yours is
to pause so every viewer can sigh and
nod their head in agreement why would a
cutthroat have a Valyrian steel attacker
it's always fun to watch a show where
the characters are six seasons behind
the viewers so we can have extremely
pointless exchanges such as this instead
of moving the story forward are you sure
it's for there in Steel it's wasted on a
[ __ ] shame on the Game of Thrones
arrow dagger makers for not being a TA
compliant dammit Thrones every time I
start to get sick ER nonsense you pull
out some incredible moment where bran
Gibbs Arya the weapon she needs to save
his life in the exact place she will
eventually use it and keep it so subtle
it only becomes evident in hindsight
combine that with actually showing the
hand switch move later in the episode
and I have no choice take your sins off
as the spoils of your foreshadowing man
Sansa really does need some new guards
now they're not even at their post this
is it 11:8 not trying to downplay Jon's
dragonglass knowledge but how could he
possibly know this is all over need
children of the forest Maddie what a
very long time ago and now John is a
cave drawing expert they were here
together the children in the flash man
and together they built an empire on the
manufacturing of family stickers for the
back of your minivan and you say you
can't defeat them without my armies and
my dragons good thing that children of
the corn forest or whatever the hell
they are called decided to caves
position all over these walls then huh
but if you use then to mount castles and
burn cities you're not different
what a beautiful relationship and such
great advice with all the pain the show
has put us through at least these two
will never have anything come between
them and the mother of dragons will
remain sane and heroic throughout the
rest of the series he didn't beat the
hound
did did she Arya ditching
ha a good heart I've notice just staring
at a good heart it's great that John can
see the good in people that might be his
greatest oh he's talking about boobs
isn't he
we don't have marriage in Nath's so the
concept of a bastard doesn't exist yeah
but you were kidnapped young and lived
most of your life in Essos yet somehow
you can't remember what a bastard is
oh well that forgetfulness sandy she'd
forget her head if it wasn't attached to
her shoulders it's a great choice [ __ ]
as long as it's not far beyond beyond
isn't it damn it we thought you were
dead
should be damn Skippy all the dough
safely through the gates of King's
Landing that was fast
weren't they in Highgarden like 20
minutes ago according to an unofficial
map I read on the internet that's like
760 miles away we basically confirmed
teleportation at this point right with
your permission
vlogging stragglers as a marked effect
on mobility let's give them fair warning
first these to sound like parents
arguing about whether or not they should
spank their children of all the topics I
thought Game of Thrones might address I
can assure you this was not one of them
mr. Jamie brake on dick on I'm not
saying this didn't make me chuckle but I
am saying this exchange would feel more
at home in an Austin Powers movie than
an episode of Game of Thrones we can
hold them off
[Music]
with that being said sending your dragon
in with the Dothraki charge what a novel
idea can't imagine it being done any
other way now that we've seen how well
it works
damn this scene is just the baddest
badass of all the asses honestly whoever
storyboarded this scene deserves all the
credit in fact I'm sitting the show for
not flashing their name in big bold
letters through the entire scene I get
this Daenerys is immune to the flames
but how are the Dothraki and the horses
not who's there also daikon ex machina
was the name I gave my penis when my
college girlfriend refused to name it he
dumped me shortly thereafter because and
I quote I lacked creativity every single
other card is full on blazing but the
one housing the Scorpion was thankfully
made out of fireproof wood and tarp so
if these arms weren't out yet how did he
shoot that unlucky Dothraki soldier
before he opened it up geez how deep of
the Westeros lakes right by the banks 30
40 feet does that seem right it's just
so magical to me to come from the north
where it's cold to the south where it's
warm I imagine you've seen things most
men wouldn't believe I've seen
however long my let's go he was always
first like to talk to you about your
list I didn't tell you because the
Deadpool is just a harmless game sounds
pretty sick to me
are you gotta be kidding me
this is the end
[Music]